[Music]
[Applause]
and Ross Tucker Westwood W CBS Sports
NFL and college football analyst former
offensive lineman and you can hear him
on the Ross Tucker football podcast
let's see he he's uh had the Broncos
Bills game on Westwood one on Monday
night he's got Coastal Carolina and army
this Saturday and uh he'll be at Iowa
Nebraska for CBS on Black Friday the
paretic Ross Tucker joining us on the
program all right let me go back to the
Buffalo Broncos game what did you see
with Buffalo's offense that would get
Ken dorsy
fired well it's interesting in that game
in particular Dan because I saw a bunch
of drops by the Bills receivers I mean
you think about the first interception
by Josh Allen the bills are moving the
ball they're in scoring range it went
right through Gabe Davis's hands that's
not Ken dorsey's fault now I will say
this Dan I don't I don't know that dorsy
is doing a great job you talk to people
schematically I think dorsy is probably
just okay the thing that's always
laughable to me about that is it's not
his fault that Dalton conade had the
drop or latavius Murray had the drop or
even that Sean McDermot third and long
the Broncos are already out of field
goal range he calls an allout Blitz
cover zero to put his guy Taran Johnson
in that position for the pass
interference and I'm pretty sure also
Dan that Ken dorsy wasn't the 12th guy
on the field on on the Miss field goal
so what I really strongly dislike about
pro football is if they win that game he
doesn't get fired so think about that if
they win that game he doesn't get fired
but they lost so mcder quote unquote has
to do something so he makes dorsy the
scapegoat makes dorsy the sacrificial
lamb just not a fan of that never happen
sometimes they'll just like randomly
fire a couple position coaches just so
that they appease the fans or the media
and show that they're doing something
are the Bills
fixable uh I don't think so this year no
I I don't know that having a new play
caller in Brady who didn't really do a
great job in Carolina is gonna is going
to solve that you know what else too I
was just thinking about this Dan I think
this is one of the issues on some level
when you have a defensive head coach and
it's a shame because I I'm not I'm not
anti- defensive head coaches but if you
have a defensive minded head coach and
your team has success that probably
means you're scoring points and the
offense is doing well well then that
guy's going to get hired away that that
guy's going to go like Dall to the
Giants and then you have to get a new
play caller a new guy and and just
sometimes that transition does not go as
smoothly and it hasn't for Buffalo and I
don't know if a new coordinator can
change Josh Allen's
style because it just feels like this is
who he is he's going to take chances he
he tries to improvise he wants a splash
play and I don't know if you could say
hey like if Bill bich was coaching the
bills could he say to Josh Allen you're
going to throw the ball 15 times Max
tonight how do you think that would go
over I don't think it would go over very
well at all and I don't think that the
the bills would move the ball very
effectively although they did run it
pretty well yeah Monday night I totally
agree Dan to me Josh Allen like we're at
the we're like at the and I want to be
careful how I say this I'm not saying
Josh Allen's a much better player than
Carson Wentz much better but you know I
do a lot of Philadelphia Media stuff and
he was so good in 2017 he could have
been the MVP if he didn't get hurt and
then 2018 and 2019 he would just have
these games where he'd have these silly
turnovers and these wild decisions
you're like what's he doing but then he
went to you know Indian the same thing
happened he went to Washington same
thing happened like at some point you
just acknowledg Carson Wentz is gonna
make stupid mistakes that's just part of
who he is totally agree with you Dan
Josh Allen is going to turn the football
over at time
now he's still worth it he's still a top
five quarterback he's still a fantastic
player but I think we have to get to the
point he's got the most turnovers over
the last six years since he's been a
starter he has the most turnovers the
last two years like at some point this
is just who he is could they maybe get
another coordinator in there that will
help him dial that back a little bit
probably but he's been playing a lot of
football now for a long time and he's
just aggressive and he's just gonna make
some mistakes that that you don't want
to see him make Thursday Night Football
the Bengals getting three and a half
against the Ravens what's the one thing
that you're looking for tonight probably
all of the injuries and the impact on
the game I don't think it's being talked
about enough but Ronnie Stanley's not
going to play at left tackle for the
Ravens tonight Marlon Humphrey is
doubtful so I doubt he plays so the
Ravens don't have their left tackle and
their best corner we know T Higgins
won't play for the Bengals it sounds
like Hendrickson's going to try to play
but that has a big impact on the game I
mean no Marlon Humphrey against those
receivers for the Bengals is tough for
the Ravens and then you don't have
Ronnie Stanley but the Bengals do have
Trey Hendrickson the other thing about
it is you know it's an important game
for both teams but if the Bengals lose
this game they're in a bad spot Dan I
mean they lose this game what are they
Dro to five and five at that point and
they're on the outside looking in for
the playoffs the losses by both these
teams on Sunday and especially the way
in which they lost that actually makes
tonight's game bigger and and more
important than if they had both won last
week we're talking to Ross Tucker
Westwood won CBS sports analyst with
college football and the NFL you know
I'm just trying to figure out who's the
MVP now I know we like to do this uh we
get ahead of ourselves like first month
of the season MVP candidates and then
you know guys tend to fall off and then
reappear who is the midseason MVP in
your opinion at any
position at any well so the MVP we know
usually goes to a quarterback and I
would imagine that it still will let's
not do that let's not let's give it to
the person you think is the most
valuable not it goes to the quarterback
yeah no I think that's fair because I do
think that AJ Brown and and Tyreek Hill
should be mentioned mentioned I actually
though think if if we're really talking
about the most valuable player in the
league to this point I think is CJ
Stout I mean the Texans were terrible
the last couple years now they're five
and four they host the Cardinals if they
win that game and they're favored
they'll be six and four and in the
playoff race yeah I know we always look
at the top of the standings right to me
Dan CJ Stroud is almost like the Jaden
Daniel
of the NFL right now right like Jane
Daniels the LSU kid he's been the best
player this year you know he deserves to
win the Heisman he's been the best
player in college football but he's not
undefeated like pennx Jr or JJ McCarthy
and I get that but jayen Daniels should
win the Heisman right now CJ Stroud's
been the most valuable player the Texans
were terrible he has totally changed the
entire perception of that franchise
singlehandedly and they had injuries on
the o line they had a bunch of games
where they didn't have either tackle
their receivers we thought were
pedestrian he's making Noah Brown and
these guys tank Dell look like stars
there has not been a more valuable
player in the National Football League
this year than CJ strad the quarterback
for the Houston Texans he probably won't
win it but he's the most valuable player
so far in my mind one of the Broncos
receiver Courtland Sutton I think said
uh that we owe Russell Wilson an
apology um does the media owe Russell
Wilson an
apology no he was awful last year I mean
unless you're gonna say that that was
all entirely because of Nathaniel hacket
and that it wasn't Russell Wilson's
fault but he was still the guy pulling
the trigger he was still the guy playing
and I don't think he's playing great
this year I mean look he's way better
than he was last year he's not a top
five quarterback probably still not even
a top 10 quarterback last year he was a
bottom five player at that position he's
played much better um I don't think we
owe him an apology I think we probably
owe Shawn pton a lot of credit I mean
Shawn pyton this is why he's getting 18
million a year they they literally are
paying Payton that much because they
wanted to see they I think the Broncos
thought if anyone can maximize
whatever's still left in Russell Wilson
it's Shawn pyton and you know what Dan
he's doing it I mean they're not crazy
numbers but he's got you know four times
more touchdowns and he does
interceptions he's taking care of the
football they're winning games now I
think Payton deserves a lot of credit
more so than giving Russell Wilson
apology just call it like it is he's
playing better than last year and he
deserves credit for that are the Browns
cursed yeah I think they are it's not
just the Sean Watson Dan I mean they
they lost both offensive tackles
Concklin and wills they lose Nick chub
earlier we know this is like a make or
break year for their head coach Kevin
stefansky and their GM Andrew Barry
you're gonna lose both tackles your star
running back and after your best win in
probably three years since the playoff
win against the Steelers your best win
in two or three years where your your
franchise quarterback is perfect in the
second half you come from behind against
division leading Ravens then we find out
Wednesday out of the blue he has to have
shoulder surgery done for the year why
can't the Browns have nice things their
fans are unbelievable they have like the
most loyal fans they have done almost
nothing since the Browns came back in 99
for those people to still be as DieHard
and as loyal as they are they've had
like two halfway decent years that whole
time and the fans are finally fired up
finally excited I mean that must have
been one of the alltime punches in the
gut 900 am yesterday morning Browns Fe
fans are feeling as good as they felt in
years and then boom it's like when you
get punched in the stomach and you're
not ready almost like a a a pie in the
face and you're not ready for it if you
had to bet on Bill bich che's
future where would you
bet I would bet that he is the head
coach for either the Washington
commanders or the Carolina Panthers
next year I think there's a decent
chance that is not a patient owner in
Carolina Frank Reich Dan when you watch
him talk he kind of looks like a guy
that knows he might be one and done he
really does and I think as bad as it's
been for New England this year I think
teer and Harris their hedge fund
backgrounds enable them to not a let one
bad year affect what someone's done in a
larger sample size a larger body of work
those guys have both had a bad year in
their hedge funds every once in a while
right and I think that they believe that
bich gives them instant credibility he
would hopefully set the record for wins
while he's coaching them I think he
coaches one of those two franchises next
year great to talk to you safe travels
thanks always thank you so much Dan
appreciate it Ross Tucker our good buddy
the Ros Tucker football podcast can be
found on social media at Ros Tucker uh
at uh Ros Tucker NFL Westwood One CBS
Sports NFL college football analyst
always great to talk to him